[Musique]
durant trois jours le salon de
l'écologie prend place à la norvèze Parc
des Expositions à Saint-Denis le
département présent au salon célèbre les
30 ans de préservation des espaces
naturels sensibles et de la biodiversité
30 ans d'engagement de valorisation et
de partage
le département a mis en place un plan de
transition écologique et solidaire
notamment avec des actions sur la
conservation des de notre patrimoine
naturel avec le plan 1 million d'art
donc la restauration la conservation de
notre patrimoine avec la plantation
d'arbres indigènes et endémique on a
aussi tout volé sobriété énergétique on
a également la mise en place d'un plan
de gestion des déchets en interne la
mise en place d'un plan de mobilité donc
le département est vraiment une
collectivité proactive et c'était
important qu'on puisse la valoriser
aujourd'hui sur ce salon de l'écologie
au programme une plongée au cœur des
forêts dans l'espace sensoriel ou encore
le survol des sites remarquables du
maille d’eau de Cap Blanc de la forêt de
belloube et du volcan les équipes de la
collectivité sont également présents
pour animer divers ateliers
un atelier sur la journée de vendredi de
découverte des espèces indigènes on a
recréé donc une sur notre stand et on va
pouvoir proposer au public de toucher
sentir regarder apprécier différencier
nos pieds de boîte on retrouve dans nos
forêts qu'on a ramené ici à proximité du
public on présente un atelier sur la
biodiversité aquatique donc on présente
les communautés du vivant les espèces
présentent localement dans nos cours
d'eau et on va parler notamment des
différents types de milieux aquatiques
liés à la Réunion
les cycles biologiques des espèces
notamment parlé du Vichy qui et du Cabot
Boucheron et puis aussi de la chaîne
alimentaire et de l'obstination de la
planète avec le phytoplancton qui est
très important pour nous voir le
phytopension en vrai le jeu canton en
vrai ces petits animaux microscopiques
qui sont vraiment très importants pour
la chaîne alimentaire notamment le
phytoplancton pour l'oxygénation de la
planète puisqu'il fournit deux tiers
d'oxygénération de la taille retrouver
le département de La Réunion au salon de
l'écologie les 16 17 et 18 septembre de
9h à 17 heures
[Musique]